-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning
and Tony-nominated
comedian and writer you know
her from her work on "SNL,"
"30 Rock," and "Girls5eva,"
as well as films
such as "Mean Girls"
and "Sisters."
You can see her
alongside Amy Poehler
on their upcoming
Restless Leg Tour.
For more information,
go to TinaAmyTour.com.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Tina Fey, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Oh, thank you.
-Now, one could say this
is a promotional appearance
for your new tour,
but it's already worthless.
-Yes. I got an e-mail last night
saying, "Don't promote the tour.
The tour is sold out!"
-Amazing!
This is two days.
-The tour is sold out.
-Two days?
-In two days, yes.
So, these first four cities
are sold out.
So I have no reason
to talk to you.
-Okay. Well...
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-And this is always --
You've made it very clear
from the day we met
all our conversations
had to be quid pro quo, yeah.
-Yes, yeah.
-But this is so exciting.
Obviously, you and Amy have
known each other for 30 years.
-Yeah.
-It seems --
It's hard not to think of
Steve and Marty,
Steve Martin and Marty Short,
who would go out
and do a show like this.
Did you talk to them about it?
-I mean, obviously,
Steve Martin and Martin Short
were kind of
the inspiration for this,
because they so these live shows
because they just love
hanging out with each other.
And so we thought,
"Maybe, you know, we could do
something like that."
And the older that we get,
the more Marty looks like me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So I was like,
"Yeah, we could do this."
And I did, actually --
They're so lovely, those guys.
And I did hear from them.
Got a lovely e-mail from
Steve Martin, that said, like,
you know, about
the announcements that,
"We're so excited for you,
and if you want to help
promote the show, you could say,
'This tour will be just like
Steve and Marty's tour,
but without the old-man smell.'"
[ Laughter ]
Which I thought that was so --
-Very, very good.
-But I do think we will have a
fair amount of old-man smell.
-And have you heard from Marty?
-Yeah, well, Marty of course
had to chime in on the chain
and said like, "So excited.
I can't wait to see which one
of you will turn out to be
the Steve of the duo
and which one will
entertain the audience."
-Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect Marty joke.
-Perfect...
-I will say Restless Leg Tour,
an excellent title.
-Poehler.
-Poehler came up with it?
Did you bandy about
a bunch of names?
-We had a long list of names.
My friend, Janine Brito,
said we should call it like
"'90s, 2000s, and Today,"
like a contemporary
radio station.
But we had, yeah,
all kinds of different things,
but then Amy
just one day just said,
"What about
Restless Leg Tour?"
And it didn't make
literal sense,
but it makes emotional sense.
-It does.
-And that's what we're about.
-It's very exciting.
I mean, I've talked
at length about the fact
that now, my goodness,
I probably saw you guys
onstage 25 years ago in Chicago,
in a tiny, little stage.
-Yeah.
-And now you're gonna be
on these big stages.
You have to obviously figure out
what you're going to do.
You have nothing
but stories, like --
-Yeah, we have stories to tell
and we answer questions
and stuff.
And, you know, I do think we --
You know,
Amy and I have skills that
we haven't shown people yet.
-Oh, interesting.
-Amy's really good at guessing
what pills people are on.
[ Laughter ]
-She's really good at that.
-Right? You know that.
-I re-- It's really --
I didn't even know
people were on pills
until I met Poehler.
-Yeah. Oh, no.
Poehler will tell you,
everyone is on pills.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Wally, you've probably
seen her do it, yeah.
And I'm not gonna brag,
but I'm also, like,
pretty good at wall sits.
-Wall sits?
-So that might be,
like, a big part of the night,
just me doing wall sits.
-Wall sits being the exercise
where you put your back
against the wall?
It's, like, a quad exercise.
-Yeah.
-Gotcha.
-So, I feel like
that's an hour right there.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it is very funny
to think of, like, one of those
old sort of, like -- What is it?
Those mentalist shows
where someone, like,
tells a lady
what's in her purse,
but it's just Amy
guessing the pills.
-Yes. Oh, my God. Yes.
We should do it to the audience.
-And you go in the audience
and you just, like...
-And I touch --
I look at everyone's pills.
We have a camera
that sees everyone's pills
before they come in.
-Yeah, you say
it's a metal detector,
but it's just a pill machine.
-Sure. [ Laughs ]
Should we have called it
"We Know You're on Pills"?
[ Laughter ]
This is also very exciting.
You obviously have this going
on, which is very exciting.
You also have --
"Mean Girls" was a movie.
Then "Mean Girls"
was a musical on Broadway.
And now "Mean Girls" the musical
is gonna be a movie again.
-Yes.
-Full circle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep.
-And you're starting soon.
-And we're starting March 6th.
We have an amazing cast.
I'm super-excited
about this cast.
Reneé Rapp from --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, from
"Sex Lives of College Girls"
and is a pop star
is gonna play Regina George.
-That's great.
-Angourie Rice, who you may know
from "Mare of Easttown"
and "Senior Year" --
she's gonna play Cady.
Jaquel Spivey, who was on
"Strange Loop" in Broadway,
Tony nominee,
is playing Damian.
Oh, Auli'i Cravalho --
It's just an incredible cast.
-And, also,
don't sell yourself short.
-And also [Laughs]
[Coughs] me and Tim Meadows.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, I do want to
give you credit.
Like, you and Tim had parts
in the original film
that you couldn't age out of,
whereas --
-We couldn't age out of.
Teachers work forever.
I do want it to be like --
I want it to be like
when Gilligan from
"Gilligan's Island"
was at a trade show,
and you'd be like,
"Oh, he looks so old
in his little hat."
-[ Laughs ]
That's your goal.
-That's my goal.
[ Laughs ]
-What is -- And do you have to
adjust the Broadway songs
to the film?
-Yes, the songs are sounding --
It's really a more kind of pop.
And it's a fascinating process,
actually, because you kind of --
In Broadway,
everything has to play
to the back of the house,
and then movies,
you can kind of come back in
and things can play
really intimately.
And it's -- We have a very cool
directing team,
very cool choreographer.
It's gonna be...
[ Clicks tongue ]
-Wow.
-Yeah, it's gonna be good.
-You do not do that many
clicks when you're lying.
-Unh-unh.
[ Laughter ]
-I have a ton more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Tina Fey, everybody!